- [Narrator] This is
the dictator scorpion.
Growing up to eight inches in length,
it is one of the largest
scorpions in the world.
For its colossal size,
the dictator scorpion
has relatively weak venom, so for defense
it resorts to its enormous claws.
They help it to catch prey and ward off
other scorpions.
Located within the region of West Africa,
the dictator scorpion is nocturnal,
spending most of its life underground,
sometimes burrowing as deep as six feet.
Unfortunately, size doesn't
matter when it comes
to the preservation of
the dictator scorpion.
With their natural
habitats being destroyed
by deforestation, its future is uncertain.
This is the dictator scorpion.